it's a it's a bloody Mars rover hello
everyone you join me
Harlow town it's a train station where
apparently the electricity is stopped
working in the signals or something like
that and I can't get any trains home
I've been stuck here for about an hour
and I've been meaning to film this bit
for the vlog talking about what happened
in October I don't know if you can tell
but I am chest infection I'm on
antibiotics I'm just a bit a poorly boy
something we see you slipping a bit of a
theme this month
[Music]
it has been a really crappy start to the
month I won't lie oh that's it
it's like 12:00 noon I'm still in my
pajamas because I have got the double
whammy of horrible cold which has been
over the past couple of days and all of
my wisdom teeth is decided to make an
unexpected appearance so that's that's
hunky-dory so I can't sleep and during
the day I'm useless so yay I did get an
email that I've been waiting for for
like two months
now which is that my PhD Corrections
have been approved and I feel like I
should be really ecstatic and like
jumping up in the air about this but to
be sure when I got the email
I literally just collapsed on the floor
but this means that I am now officially
done with the PhD the examiners don't
want to see it again they've suggested a
few final extra changes that's like
another round of changes but it's very
minor things and then I loaded the
university system and I graduate in
December and the PhD journey is it's got
one more step I still have to graduate I
is the final step that is actually
happening I just wish I wasn't so
excited like I could actually appreciate
it
so today isn't gonna be a terribly
productive day just like yesterday
wasn't just like the day before that
wasn't the pker today is gonna be
installing some new memory into my
computer because After Effects keeps
crashing it I got this computer in 2013
so it's probably about time
that graded anyway but especially when
you do as much stuff in Premiere and
after-effects as I do
16 gigs of memory isn't very much and I
keep getting stuff crashing especially
if I have like premier and Chrome open
at the same time so going in tinkering
here we are the guts of my computer
where various underperforming internet
videos have come from that's what the
memory is going those tool things I
might be about to absolutely screw
myself here if I don't do any videos for
a while it was because of this
okay so I just restarted it and I just
got what I think of as a death beep like
a beep that doesn't know what I mean
it's not a good beep and the screens are
black oh my god I missed the cable
that's why yeah so maybe a terrible
start to the month and I may be way
behind what I want to be on work and
there are so many videos I want to do in
the next couple of weeks I can't but I
did something for the first time today
this is all right there's computer
business all right
so Paul loved options Christmas is
lumination feast and we will actually so
I am back in Exeter this weekend because
then if you can see it on my tie this is
a chapel quiet alumni weekend would come
back to do a spot for singing
[Music]
[Applause]
so this weekend all the alumni of the
chapel can come back to sing we are
about to doing the Sun which the current
chapel cars can do most of we're
basically joining him for a bit and then
there is a concert and later but it's
kind of amazing I was in the chapel at
for four years coming back feels like
nothing's changed
you know it's only the faces that change
the whole atmosphere this building's
still as amazing as ever was and we
really just warmed up a little bit but
singing you go everyone is back look at
him
actually more than that we've got Hugo
and we have Cora and so it's means that
we have the entire basement beer mile is
ready a little bit of spillage village
is of course leakage I believe that's
off let's see you go and he's away he's
away first track Simon he's away again
I've heard worse ideas great a banger
[Music]
so the service was a lot of fun even
some if you are haven't followed me for
a while you don't know what evensong is
I did a whole video about what the
different things that you do in tap
acquire are including some seven out of
ten singing for me which is alright but
not an amazing I could definitely do
better it's sort of strange to not be
following the choir out like you know
all the members the choir leave at the
end and then we're still stood here
what's at it in the stores so
bittersweet actually I've got a concert
next
[Music]
[Applause]
so we just ate after rehearsal very busy
weekend we're trying to Snug that in now
we've got to do a concert I found you a
nice little safe spot you find up here
I'm just gonna gonna put you on I'm
gonna go sing okay Jonah say goodbye it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was fun so you can actually
watch and listen to the whole concert on
the chapel's Facebook page which I'll
link to the video below because we try
and of course don't we anymore they try
and livestream as much as possible now
so you can actually listen to the whole
thing what is amazing when you listen to
that is some of the music is incredibly
difficult so for example Lord let me
know my names which is by peri part of
the songs about well very very difficult
piece this is the third week of term the
choral scholars did their first like the
new choral scholars who join the choir
this year because of course it's a
student body it gets updated every year
the new scholars only joined last week
they have had a week to learn a whole
concert of really quite difficult
repertoire like doing fair as the heaven
Lord let me know mine n means sleep by
Whitaker it's not the easiest thing in
the world I was honestly astonished by
the quality of the new scholars I think
the sound is amazing if you're an Exeter
you're at Exeter you absolutely should
come and hear them sing because I think
this is the best I've ever heard before
really really impressive out here being
this hill my chest is infected
inconsiderate electrons so mid-month
simon decided that apparently this was
all getting a bit too exciting need a
bit of grounding and some social reality
so here you go I feel like with the
monthly vlog format where you curate
even more than normal what you portray
on camera you run the risk of portraying
your life as being a never ending
sequence of trips to various places
giving talks filming videos all these
exciting things you lose sight of the
fact that most days are kind of boring
and normal so I wanted to film today
because today is an utterly
unexceptional day today has so far been
entirely spent reply to emails writing
video scripts and generally just trying
to get my life in shape I've spent
almost the entire day in my office I
went to the gym first thing which I now
do because I've all gets up at bar 6 so
I go to the gym between like 7 9 so that
got me out of the house but today is a
pretty representative example of what
most of the month is like it is being in
this office in this chair looking at
these two screens and either writing or
editing or administrating that's pretty
much it today is more interesting than
most days actually because I've been
planning several videos all at once so
there's a black holes video which should
be out by the time this comes out
there's the video about check pulse
amplification about lasers which should
also be out there's the Mars video about
our Martian Rovers which has to be out
by the time this book comes out and then
there's all the other stuff that sort of
slightly further in the future so
there's been a lot of stuff a lot balls
in the air basically plus the small
matter of today I said that I was going
to you know finish footlight update to
my thesis to the final version and
uploaded to the university system that
small thing but yeah today has mostly
been very mundane work and I I wrote a
blog recently about
the distinction between the reality and
what it is that youtubers portray I'll
leave it
link in the description I have a blog by
the way and I do think that youtubers
have a responsibility to draw attention
to what it is that we're doing it's the
fact that the reality would portray
isn't real and I think not enough people
know that and so I wanted to include
this segment in the vlog because this is
what life is like for me for the most
part one of the most revealing videos I
ever watched I remember was back in the
day way back in the day chaos I did a
video just like a week in his life I
think just showing basically the fact
that he was editing morning till night
and that was pretty much what he did and
I want it to be known that until I say
otherwise this is what my life looks
like it is in front of these two screens
it is doing a lot of writing and a lot
of editing now though let's go back to
the more interesting stuff oh look this
is where I put my train home if I had
one oh and when I say more interesting I
mean Mars
it's a bloody Mars rover so this is the
Mars yard in Stevenage which is where
Airbus are currently testing there's one
behind me and there's one currently
being looked at at the moment Mars
rovers we're here to do a video I say we
because it is me and in Nathe from draw
curiosity who finished
she just submitted a PhD like less than
a week ago less than a week ago it
doesn't feel like a week as pastors do
how much did you sleep this weekend 27
out of
eight hours totally legit then the
previous three days except about four
hours so you know on average I've still
had asleep then what is it like for you
on the other side of handing in it
doesn't feel real yet and it doesn't
feel real and I still feel guilty all
the time not working for not working I
don't know what's wrong with me I don't
think I've got to bed at a single normal
time or gotten up at a normal time
accepted today actually yeah we had to
force her to get today's been the first
day that my sleep cycle is the first
normal day you've had you've gone to
Mars exactly how weird my circadian
rhythm has literally been on some part
of the planet that wasn't Earth and the
day I go to Mars by the way but for
those of you don't know an ace you've
been on my channel a couple of times
haven't he when we went to VidCon in
Amsterdam for example Cory you and the
Berlin yes it was at Merck we did a
thing on curiosity if you divorce your
channel about for those of you who might
not know who you are it's the strange
person with really long hair who's just
appeared on the chapel I run the channel
hold your curiosity which is about
things that draw my curiosity generally
biology engineering math see stuff you
have not been on my channel except to
the curiosity videos I know I haven't
naturally sort something out about that
but yeah I've been kind of gone due to
the PhD which fun fact actually started
growing my hair when I came to
university once upon a time I had short
hair I refused to believe I can only
ever imagine you eight years later got
this I continued a question for you on
television
oh I'll be funny and then your PhD was
on what specifically so I studied is
like biomechanics Oh a mixture of
biology and engineering I was looking at
kinematics so basically how did these
three species of fly move their wings
and their bodies we use high-speed
cameras and lasers lots of cool tech it
was a hot ball do you have engineering
can you describe to us pretty much yeah
yeah so if you found the flying Beast
video that I did interesting but an ace
has got it covered from the third angle
which is insects where I only focused on
birds and bats I saw why did you not
tell me about this Oh long enough as it
was so today we've been doing footage of
this roba who is autonomous in the sense
that they will give it a location that's
gonna drive to a minute guides itself
with a pair of cameras
so four cameras actually they were on
the rover so we've been taking footage
map happening and now we're about to do
some interviews with the engineers and
then whatever two camera shots and
things that we need for our videos
because we're both doing videos and
sponsorship without us and I'm right
here it's quite a hectic trip this one
incidentally I asked this is meant to be
a recreation of the Martian surface
I asked what this is it's the stuff that
you get the fines even this is the stuff
that you get an astroturf like the stuff
that gets stuck in your wounds when you
fall over and that apparently is the
Martian surface well the closest we have
to an earth so whilst that other rover
was autonomous this one is currently
being driven by an xbox controller
because if it ain't broke don't fix it
yeah I think Oh God
where's where's the fire button full
pointer and then illustrate man
whilst it's rotating
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so this weekend I'm back home for those
of you who've watched my channel for a
while you may recognize this is my room
at my parents house
the reason the back this weekend is
because it's my dad's birthday
he's turning 64 and pixel and I or pixel
girl drove us back here to surprise him
so it was it was nice to come out last
night and to give him a bit of a
surprise and I'm kicking Jennifer in
tonight but because my mum knew we were
coming
sort of help to set this up she's taking
the opportunity to lay out a bunch of my
old school portraits and what let's have
a look at shall we get the development
of of me to begin with there's a bunch
of photos of me in the bath and I don't
really know why that's my cat Henry who
I still miss dearly so starting in year
one when mr. Wayne his class that's me
they look quite cute that's Charlie
McDonnell looking very cute let's move
on to year two suddenly I'm not really
so cute
because I'm not quite sure what happened
to be honest there's I mean from the X
Factor Charlie McDonnell
oh there he is yeah one assignment boy
like an 8 out of 10 on the cuteness
scale you to Simon's solid then over
here near four I mean I guess that's
about three really not the best is it
guys yeah five Simon's poor you like a
five out of ten it's not too bad no
judging people race on earth I'm judging
me
also in this picture is Matthew Pierce
of the birther Mattie piss fanclub on
Jeremy Kyle thing
taking pure bio six something has been
recovered that I mean it's still no good
it does put four out of ten
and then by year seven apparently I
became a very serious young barrister
that is the face of a determined boy
look at that fat determined boy picks
will go which is your favorite version
assignment in these pictures I think I
just died of it in size oh it's okay so
is a fun family trip whilst we're here
we're going into the Sun ah we're going
off to a local National Trust place
which is Durham Park how excited are you
pick Savelle she's not feeling too
terribly well today and extended the
length through his town maybe by two
centimeters because the clearance is a
genuine story
[Music]
to england's full of these National
Trust properties and they often stately
homes or places of historical interest
what's great about Durham it's what's in
front of me
[Music]
so can you turn the other way please
that's it thank you yes
work it the buck stops here he's glaring
at me for that one not a bad view again
there's something about these wide-open
views whether it's like just so much sky
lighting to stretch it's above you in
every direction absolutely love it I
also love autumn so this is this is
pretty perfect right now
[Music]
parish churches in England they're
always interesting to me because they
have to go back the century is this one
I think was from the 13th century but
this one's particularly interesting
because it's a parish church so all the
local populace you know worshiped here
and it's got you know rolls of their
deaths and baptisms and there's a war
memorial people diving for first and
second world wars here but this is in
the grounds of a bend in the parish
there's a grand stately home you know
where we're about to go into so you
actually have rather interesting people
buried in these places like Knights
several centuries ago so it's sort of
tale of two kinds of people the common
folk and and the the rich ruling class
and you know these gardens are all right
a gasps okay it's kind of property girls
really isn't it
[Music]
hey everyone as you may be able to tell
I don't feel so good
mr. stark my pixel go and I have come
down with really heavy colds my nose is
completely completely buttoned up she's
still at work I'm still working but oh
boy temple working this is just an
occupational hazard of dating a teacher
like she gets exposed to hundreds of
snotty little kids every day I get
exposed to her every day and so she gets
ill I get ill we all scream wait we seem
to be getting quite a few colds at the
moment I'm hoping this isn't gonna be
continuous but at the moment this feels
like the way that a dating a teacher is
going which is it's a price worth paying
have involved for a couple of days
because not a huge amount interesting
has been happening my birthday happened
but I was working all day and pickles
got and I just went out for a meal at
the Wow I still literally sound like I'm
from New Zealand it was so it's so bunda
we just went out for a meal I'm really
uncomfortably close we just went out for
a meal so it wasn't really anything to
flock it was just a very quiet personal
birthday but it was nice since then I
have been working on the Mars rover
video which is coming out later today
I've just been I don't if you can see
behind that's me working on the
thumbnail incidentally actually free tip
for all the youtubers out there if you
ought to make if you want to make more
effective thumbnails go to thumbs up TV
and then basically you can drag in your
image it is sixteen by nine don't know
why it gives me that warning and then
you can type in your own your topic
video title and what it does is it shows
you what your video is gonna look like
on different platforms so you can make
sure for example that the duration isn't
going to cover up it isn't going to
cover up any information in the
thumbnail so it's really effective tool
and you know it allows you to see if
your title is gonna be cropped or
anything like that
I highly recommend it it's a free tool
for anyone to use that
standard has created really useful
that's coming out later today and then
for most of today I am going to be
writing the next science video which is
about black holes ah is there something
else that I'm doing today though is is
doing some comfort baking I really like
baking and I I just need some comfort
right now because I'm trying to think of
a script that this black hole strips on
my head but I yeah brains not working
properly I'm gonna be making rock cakes
from this book which is the best baking
book over the use this is the margarita
pattern classic cookbook she's like old
school she does things properly but in a
simple way in this highly recommend it
not not not a spinal our man doing dink
baking spawns to be amazing
oh wait I could do this like a student
youtuber wait cute that time-lapse so I
learn how to do baking from my mom
very important influence for me I'm not
actually vegan so I don't really fit in
with the study chief was oh wait we
changed the angle I ran out of foot
okay finally on the way back home yeah
it wasn't just me that was ill the
camera was too the battery died Oh
literally like two hours after I wanted
to be but here in the end and that's it
for this month
vlog by the way there isn't going to be
a vlog next month because almost
certainly no one's watched this because
almost nobody watched the last one it
just seems like long-form vlog content
just isn't feasible on YouTube you know
don't don't hate the player hate the
game I am gonna vlog in future as stuff
happens to me but it's gonna be shorter
form vlogs just as and when ad-hoc not
on a regular schedule so you will see me
vlog again when something interesting
happens which hopefully won't be too
long it is real shame because I really
like doing this format and sort of inter
stitching two different stories over the
top of one another and it allows you to
play around the editing a bit more but
it just isn't feasible so unfortunately
it's not going to continue but there we
go
I enjoyed doing this series of laws that
lasted screaming me in the comments if
you want it's all good engagement give
it a like give it a share if you think
this format should be more popular than
it is it's not going to come back but
you can if you want thank you for
watching if you made it this far and I
will see you in the next video
[Music]